let's talk about the next thing that
we're seeing this is this is i i gotta
admit
i saw this story and i'm laughing quote
we all quit
restaurant signs claiming staff walking
out are popping up across the u.s
these tweets are something else there's
on chipotle on burger king on wendy's
mcdonald's signs being like we're closed
because no one showed up today
there are signs people putting up saying
we refuse to work for such little wages
right and there's a couple of things for
one we know
biden is basically paying people more
money to not work than they could get
from working
but also inflation so if people you you
mentioned earlier that people
40 of their weekly budget is going to
food so if you're working
at a fast food restaurant it doesn't
matter if you're getting 15 an hour or
20
an hour what matters is how much food
can you afford to buy in the wheat
at the end of the week they could pay
you a thousand dollars or ten thousand
dollars
but if your food costs four thousand
dollars ten thousand doesn't mean
anything
that's exactly right i mean if you can
keep getting your rate wages
raised but the price of food goes higher
than they're raising the wages that
you're getting a cut and pay
so what happens in argentina venezuela
that's what's happening right now they
keep printing like mad but
they can't control inflation and the
policy makers will say there's no
inflation because their banking
constituents want that zero percent
money to keep consolidating and mergers
and acquisitions and leverage buyouts so
they say it's at one point six percent
even though it has a patent false but
the supply
the supply situation is going to be
something we can't hide so
you have the shortages of all these
microchips that's affecting all sorts of
of the economy the the problem with
labor is a real
genuine problem and just in the drive up
here we saw
hundreds and hundreds of signs all over
the place
begging people to come apply for jobs
even in the middle of a
field like there was a sign domino's
looking for a bunch of drivers
and a sign of advertising for domino's
jobs yeah
they're going to hire cows all right
wait wait wait wait wait
order more vinegar we got to start
buying whatever we can
yeah yeah people start hoarding which
then it feeds an inflationary cycle
then prices go up because that but i'll
get the vinegar first i just bought 150
pounds of flour
no no i already bought you 100 pounds of
flour hey i got 150 more but it's
that it's that sort of mindset the
mindset the psychology is what is really
important to hyperinflation
or whatever i mean but the other point i
want to make is like i was just
retweeted a story a day or two ago about
in durham north carolina which is a
pretty big city outside of raleigh
and um they can't find 9-1-1 operators
so they're having to divert they had to
admit that they've been diverting calls
to raleigh
uh overnight because there's you know
the economy's been
hollowed out right through private
equity deals cheap money
borrowing and debt so it's been hollowed
out it's just a shell that's cracking in
real time
all that money was stolen trillions were
stolen
stolen from the economy it's fragile
like a sh
an eggshell it's cracking the people are
now on the streets
and the revolution is in the air so you
guys have seen the wolf of wall street
no i never saw you never saw it but max
worked on wall street
so this was like uh you know in the film
you basically have a bunch of coked out
drugged out wall street guys being like
yeah
stop talking about maps like that and
they're just like
i'm not saying they they know that
they're yeah i'm not selling i'm staying
but but it's like these people know that
they're ripping people off basically
like they're just extracting
access to resources and value from a
system without providing anything to it
that's right
wall street my job on wall street it was
a microcosm of the economy as a whole
so the by word as a stock broker is do
whatever you can to get commissions and
we've got lawyers
there there's no such thing as the rule
of law on wall street
you you get the commission first and if
the feds come
after you you deal with it later you
hire pay the fund you pay fines
you know uh wall street keeps 90 cents
of every dollar they steal
right 10 cents goes to the fines or the
great thing about wall street is that
they just change the law
for example when a citigroup bought
travelers it's a big
multi-billion dollar deal they broke the
glass-steagall law that had been in
place since the 30s
they simply retroactively changed the
law and said we're going to change the
law and it
retroactively applies to that deal there
are there are there is no rule of law
on wall street fully but it's it's i
think it's just the
the rot goes deeper than this have you
guys ever seen these things they're
called like power bracelets or balance
bracelets
they're they're rubber bands that they
sell for like 30 bucks
and they tell you they say when you wear
it it improves your balance
and they use a trick called the center
of gravity illusion it's really simple
you ask someone to stand with their feet
together and their arms straight at
their sides
you then put your hand on their arm and
pull downward
slightly away from their body they'll
fall over then you put the wristband on
their hand
and then you push slightly into their
body and they won't fall over
but you can actually like hang because
you're pushing towards their center of
gravity
sales people in i would see them in
these malls they'd be doing this trick
and i'm thinking to myself
i know how the trick works you could do
it with a rock you could do with
anything
how are they getting away with selling
rubber bands for 30 bucks and lying to
people
so i looked it up it's very simple
someone will start a company
they'll knowingly defraud people the ftc
would come in and say you gotta you
gotta pay us five million dollars and
they go oh no
we only made ten here's your five here's
your cut and then they take that money
and they do the same thing with a new
company a new entity
and they sell trash products pay their
fine start a new company trash products
and they get you know destroyed shut
down but the government's getting a cut
of it
so instead of actually policing these
companies and saying stop doing this
they're like you know so long as we get
money right it's called the captured
regulator
yeah so the sec and elon musk proved
this brilliantly when uh recently he
broke some
laws and he openly mocked the sec
how about austin texas when they they
banned uber because they were losing
money on the
drunk driving tickets they're like wow
we want people to drunk drive
because we made the police made so much
money from it in the city so
revolutions in the air
derivatives earlier what was the history
of the creation of derivatives because
that seemed like part of this hollowing
right so derivatives go back to the
option pricing formula for volatility
that came around during the early 80s
and under the reagan deregulatory
environment you had listed options so
listed options are essentially the first
derivative and product and so this is
simply
an option on the future price movement
of a stock
and it's a big market the options market
and then during the 80s they introduced
financial derivatives up until then it
was
confined to stocks and commodities where
the the futures contracts is
you could say is a derivative so futures
contracts have been around for hundreds
of years it's a way for agricultural
companies to hedge against
um the weather right so they can sell
their product today
just to a speculator and they they're in
there for they they don't have the risk
of
their product arriving to market and
losing everything
because they needed to plant the next
season
but with the financial derivative you
had the s p futures and bond futures and
money market fusion and forex features
so
gave banks the way to speculate on money
itself with in a highly leveraged way
and that was the beginning of financial
derivatives and that's the beginning of
when we have
a global ponzi scheme of banks
essentially
trading on inside information with each
other on
financial shenanigans in a way that was
incredibly
leveraged but you're right in the sense
that
at some point the derivatives market
became bigger than the underlying market
right so the derivatives market should
only be a fraction of the underlying
market
to give you an example of this in the
oil market for every barrel of oil
there's something like 60 000
barrels in oil derivatives right that's
how
leverage this whole thing is for for the
global economy which is let's call it a
100
trillion dollar global economy there's
more than a quadrillion
in derivatives right the quad the
derivatives market is a
multi-quadrillion dollar
market so an example that would be like
if a company loses six million dollars
in assets or something and but people
bet
on that they can make 60 million on that
6 million loss in a derivative
well one one great milestone in the
derivative business
was uh the credit default swap invention
by life masters exxon
remember the exxon valdez oil spill yeah
oh yeah uh instead of exxon suffering
uh financial calamity from that blyth
masters invented the credit default swap
where she was able to strip out bonds
from bond interest and sell the interest
separately essentially
and insulated exxon from that disaster
so they they took the event which would
have been a liability and they turned it
into a non-event
effectively wow so um that's that's just
what we call financial engineering and
it's a
and so you could say that it's a way to
slice and dice securities into
all different things if you go to the
2008 the subprime crisis
was a derivatives crisis because they
took
sub-prime mortgages which are have a
high probability of defaulting
and they mixed it with a triple-a rated
government bond and then they sold that
mixed package
as a trash to a pension fund with the
idea that well
th the probability of this collapsing is
so minute that we're going to give it
the same rating as the bond a triple a
rating
this is like the housing crisis yeah
they took so what happened well
the first time in history you had a
housing crisis and over the entire
country
and so the subprime market collapsed
spectacularly
and instead of fining or penalizing
the banks that package this garbage even
in testimony
they told congress that these were bags
of expletive
that they were selling to the goldman
sachs not only did goldman sachs
knowingly and openly sell
bags of expletives to clients excrement
yes extra man they then
made bets against their clients knowing
that the clients would blow up
so they made money on the short side
they sold their own clients short
to make money on the collapse of the
client that they knew was going to
happen because they had sold them
the bags of excrement so that's how
insidious and awful
and corrupt the sole system is it's kind
of like encouraging
your wife to go skydiving and then
taking on a massive life insurance
policy on her
and then knowing that she has no idea
right and then selling short the
the air airline company and the
skydiving company knowing that they're
going to be sued out of existence
i have to also point out that you know
while we're talking about inflation this
is the thing that's so topsy-turvy about
everything and why we have um such a
chaos
in our economic system is those
derivatives
are collapsing and that is a black hole
and that is a huge amount of deflation
right
so if that's worth nothing but it's
right now on paper
worth a quadrillion that's a lot of
money that's like many many many many
many many trillions that we'd have to
print every month
just to break even on that right so the
central bank has bought now
trillions of dollars worth of this paper
from wall street eight trillion
eight trillion dollars that they to re
liquefy wall street but that's just a
small fraction of it
right but they buy it at 100 cents on
the dollar but when you say okay what's
the resale value
it's zero so the federal reserve bank
has leveraged more than a hundred to one
which is they're leveraged more than
enron i mean enron was leveraging 80 70
or 80 to one it collapsed in a day
the the federal reserve bank has
leveraged much more than enron
it was leveraged and it could collapse
overnight because
that's the problem with the whether or
not it's inflation or deflation and this
is a debate this is
a debate that we've been having on all
of our content
for the last 15 years like nobody
economists
bankers nobody knows for sure what which
one we're actually having
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you